like marissa said my name is patrick
mcfadden um i do develop a relations
stuff here at data stacks i also
work quite a bit in our open source site
i do open source strategy
um spend most of the time giving away
software that's what i do
okay so i'm telling you to stop using
databases this is the world we live in
right when when the database becomes
like this
it's tyrannical it's just like this is
the center of the universe
and we have to like go ask it please can
i have data
i wrote this perfectly in a perfect sql
statement and it's like hmm
i don't know and
the issues that we've always run into is
that developers
especially have to really know a lot
about databases
to use them to be effective and more
importantly to
get the most out of it um if you don't
if you're using something like mysql
it's very different from implementation
from say oracle
and um and if you're using uh nosql
database like cassandra
also very different and it require it
puts a lot of knowledge
and this this thing where you have to go
pray to the altar of the database to get
the best
performance and the best use of that
database um
i've been working on this for so long i
forget sometimes that you know
i know how to optimize an sql query for
oracle because i know how to optimize
like table scans and row scans and um
cassandra same thing i know how to build
partition keys and clustering columns
that are proper that will give you sub
millisecond
performance and works well in a huge
thousand node cluster
that's a lot of to expect from somebody
who's starting
or let's say the first day that they're
there and then so what we've done is
we've created this whole
the order of the sacred dbas that we all
have to like
ask very politely and i was one of those
people
um this is a group of people that
whenever
things are not going quite the way you
expected them to
uh that you call and say hey
oracle dba my query is slow um
and i uh
i when i'm in the middle of doing like
work
as an oracle dba um
i'm in this mode where hey um
i'm going to listen to your question but
i don't think um
sorry just a minute the uh when i'm in
the mode of being an oracle dba
um i'm gonna be listening to questions
and i'm gonna try to answer them
well in that mode i i'm in the i'm just
gonna be like well
i'm gonna help you the best i can but
i'm going to be hoping that someone's
going to know what they're doing because
that's a lot of questions i'm going to
get and you know this if you're a dba
it's like
hey how come i'm you know my uh
my query is two milliseconds slower than
the last one well i don't know let me go
check the index or things like that i
mean it's just a lot of deep knowledge
and then
here's when you start learning things
like explain plan right
um and then this is i think this is
where we where we land with
using databases is we have these design
time tradeoffs
um design time tradeoffs application
and you know we're going to be building
our application and it's this meeting
you know where you're on the whiteboard
and you're saying okay look we have this
thing what are we going to build and
in that meeting you have to make
trade-off discussions
say um what are my what are the needs of
the application
uh what are the scaling requirements how
do i deploy it
and each one of those comes with a
trade-off
and the trade-offs usually are
your best guess and sometimes they're
not the best
best guess because whenever you deploy
it you learn that oh wait
the scaling requirements are completely
different or something else
so this is a really hard and probably
most stressful part of building
your application like in a design phase
is
just making the right choices and
luckily
in 2021 we have better choices that give
us
less of those problems um
and then here's this um it's funny
because we're doing this with a linux
foundation
and cncf of course we love cloud but
you all love some cloud and that has
changed so
much of how we do things now and running
databases now
um i think it from from a standpoint
of cloud and database not a whole lot
has changed there has been some changes
but
you're still probably doing like a bare
metal-ish type deployment you're still
under trying to understand a database
but that is changing
um that is hopefully going to change and
we're going to get to that in a minute
but um
the fact that you're deploying a cloud
and you're probably not racking up
hardware anywhere
because i i can't even remember the last
time i did that
it gives us a whole lot of new
opportunities right
and then kubernetes come on now that is
it's done don't ask questions of course
it's taken over
and for good reason the thing that i
have
really started to love about where
kubernetes lands in the in the
grand scheme of building applications is
you know we've
we've slowly abstracted layers over the
years
where we went from bare metal to virtual
machines to containers
we went from you know from bare metal
that we install ourselves to
instance types um then eventually to
you know running containers in the cloud
but now kubernetes
and and all of those you had to kind of
run yourself now kubernetes is
abstracting the next layer which is
abstracting entire data centers you know
kubernetes is a data center abstraction
it's virtualized data center so i
deployed an entire data center worth of
apple
an application and it is
really amazing how that is the timing is
perfect
because it keeps us from getting too
locked into one thing like if we want to
move from on-prem
but that means that we need to really
understand the entire picture
of deploying an application with
something like kubernetes because we're
building the entire
virtual data center and it needs to be
able to
hold up to our application needs
so this is where we get to the data
services so i'm saying stop using
databases
but use data services and this is a
fundamental
shift in your thinking in your
deployment everything
um and i'm gonna go into why
i don't think this will be too much of a
shock but this is a this is something
that i feel like we need to
as a community of application builders
and database professionals
we need to start thinking about things
in terms of data services just like how
we went from
deploying containers on our own data
centers to deploying in kubernetes
so a data service is pretty simple and
there have been versions of this in the
past this isn't too crazy but this is
we're getting into more a defined space
now
um data services are an abstraction
layer
um the underlying the the top line is
the apis that developers need
probably some sort of http api like rest
graphql
grpc um
the uh sql cql document
gremlin you know those are protocols
that
do work um and can work
on your database however the data
service
um really wants to abstract the layer
like it wants to
hide the implementation from the
underneath and
um this is what i think if you
look at like the left side this is
probably what you want to use mostly
anyway because
you're not thinking when you're using
rest you're not thinking wow am i using
you know am i using the right keys here
for optimize
query well that keeps our developers
from having to overthink about what's
going on below the line
and the below the line is the actual
database itself
and yes we're still using someone's
still using a database but the data
service is
abstracting that layer away and you
think about
in terms of how we deploy it that's
where it gets interesting
so so there's some great examples of
these out there
this is uh there's um
so there's a lot of these uh you know
out there already
and hang on
so whenever we have i'm sorry we've got
something that happened outside
so akio is a really interesting project
by facebook
it's a data service that um has some
really cool
features like abstracts as geographics
and things like that
at no point does the engineers that use
it have any idea what database they're
using or where it is
and that's the point they want to bring
in
uh engineers that are um
going to be ready to use or to build the
front end part of facebook
and instagram on the first day they
don't want to have them to go through
multiple days of uh learning or multiple
months of learning all the back end data
systems that's just not important
and akio takes away a lot of the really
interesting things that
um that are great for keeping your
application online but
developers shouldn't have to worry about
like data placement and replication
things like that
so when we're using a database
you have some things you can do here
like for instance
um you're something you have to do like
you have to make sure that the driver is
installed
that you have to initialize that
connection to the database
you have to create a prepared statement
then you execute the statement
and then you finally parse and use the
result this is a block diagram but this
is pretty much every database
that you use um there are
some you know there's some details in
there of course but i mean that's mainly
what we have to do every time we want to
use a database
it doesn't matter if you're using
node.js or java or whatever
um and i'm going to check are my are my
slides
advancing yes they are
okay so you have to do that checksum
so when you use a database um
is this is the way it should work right
well what happens when using data
services well we cut out a lot of that
stuff
from here we're just executing a
statement and parsing and using the
results
and what this eliminates is a lot of
stuff a lot of the ceremony
we like to call it that but it's the
am i using the correct driver for the
correct database
um am i managing my connections properly
and if i'm not what does that do to the
database
you know if you work a lot with like
oracle keeping open database connections
forever is
really a bad idea um and so uh
pool and connection pooling that sort of
things it puts a lot of burden inside of
your application code and then
eventually for application developers
because all that gets
you can you could hide it in
implementation but eventually
you know there's gonna have to be dealt
with and when you're using data services
over http
apis you're you're just providing an
endpoint
and those data services provide um
enough
get and put operations so that
developers on the front end can just
keep moving
and that's what we really want that's
the dream right
and this uh this is a great slide to
show first of all
danger iceberg but it's also
shows the implementation like this is
what we want we want this top line to
look oh it's just this cute little
iceberg out here it's very easy to use
but that messy
big mess details underneath is hidden
um and so there's a
there's some stuff happening at uh i'll
i can't name there's a lot of these
projects out there that i can't talk
about i will talk about one that i can
but um because and the reason i can't
talk about them because they haven't
quite gone open source
yet and but think of all the
hyperscalers the big companies that are
doing
scale operations they're all moving to
data services and staying away from
databases
and mainly because of the messy details
why not have a small core group of
people that manage
database operations like what if i want
to migrate from one database to another
um or i want to migrate from one data
center to another
um you know things like that or i need
to do some operations on my database
that
generally would require me to have a
negotiation with developers
no just abstract the whole thing as long
as the api is online
everything's good it gives you the
ability to change things
underneath
all right
there we go oops
so here are the three things that i
would consider criteria
for data services oops back back
you need to have on-demand scaling you
need to be elastic
meaning you just pay for what you need
so if it goes up it goes down and you
need near 100
up time um these things give you that
maximum flexibility with the minimum
amount of tradeoffs
and when you think about when you're
building applications
um and you're having
uh you're having these discussions built
in this application build time
these are three things that you would
really love to say these are not at the
problem
yeah are we gonna have enough yeah we'll
get whatever we want when we need
it is it going to be online no matter
where we are in the world yeah
should be up no problem that's what it's
built to do and then finally is it going
to blow out our budget
nope it's not going to do that because
if we don't use it it's going to
scale back down and we're not going to
have to pay for it great
okay moving on to the other thing spaces
or tabs
i'll let you figure that out for
yourself um but
we have less of a conversation around
just
data and man i'll tell you this could
really make your life better
now open source is coming to the rescue
on this one because
uh cloud databases um have started
going down this route and we know that
you know there are cloud
uh serverless databases out there or
data services that
um basically are there to lock you into
their service
and it's pretty well known you know they
they want you in their walled garden
so if you're in cloud x and they have a
very bespoke data service that works
inside of their cloud
they know if you move your data into it
you're probably going to be there for
life right
because you know how it goes oh someday
we'll move our database to this other
database and we'll be fine that's no
lock in
yeah that's called technical debt and
you're never gonna get out of that
um so this is what's been really fun to
watch with kubernetes
is because we're virtualizing data
centers and we can do this kind of stuff
like you know
create the entire application including
the data layer
we can move this thing around so if
you know if i want to running gcp amazon
and azure at the same time
totally fine if i want to just run run
at a time totally fine
but it the data portion is the key
to portability and open source to the
rescue
open source helped us a long time ago um
i remember
when i was back in the 90s remember that
um
i was working with we had operating
systems we had to pay for
a lot i mean it was solaris was not
cheap
um but you know here comes linux
and it changed our scale equation like
instead of installing
one big server we started installing
tons of little ones and they were great
and because we were using linux open
source changed the economics of it
um same with all sorts of infrastructure
um
databases mysql cassandra
analytics like spark they've changed the
the
the
whole game when it comes to the
economics of scale and
same thing's going to happen with data
services
now i work um like i said with
kubernetes
quite a bit now and this portability is
really important
especially when it comes to building
applications developers should be able
to use
their laptop uh you could run it you
know if you still have
on-prem software hardware great if you
want to run it in the cloud great
all of those things should work just
fine and not have to be really super
different like you should not have to
say well i'm going to deploy on my
laptop
it's going to be completely different
from what i'm going to deploy in
production
using kubernetes now we have the ability
to build
not only what we need but put it into a
ci cd pipeline
so that the configuration is stored and
get
our virtual data centers run in any
place that we can run kubernetes
so this this equation has changed quite
a bit
um so i work on a couple of open source
projects and i'm going to kind of get
into some
like more specific examples and this is
why i'm really one of the reasons i'm
really passionate about it is because
as someone who's been working with um
with open source databases and like
cassandra
um my sql for years um
i'm seeing like this is like the next
wave is
where we now take the data layer data
services
into kubernetes and we just use
all that good stuff that we've built
over the years
i don't think we need a new database not
at all
um there's lots of great databases out
there that do
lots of great things but what i do think
is we need a new relationship with our
databases
in a cloud-native architecture so
um i'm gonna go over some of these um
real quickly and just give you a
highlight of what they do and why we're
you know what these open source projects
are about why i think this is
the right direction so stargate
is a not only a cool name for a project
but it also does things like uh create
http apis like rest graphql
document apis and it even does native
format just like i was
showing you before in another in another
slide
but it it is built
for deploying on kubernetes
now this gives you this a lot of options
for developers it gives you lots of
options because you can just choose the
right api or client a framework
and it it abstracts away a lot of stuff
and it's
it's not easy because sometimes you have
to think about
um what's under you know there is some
thought
when you deploy it about how you deploy
it with your software or with your
underlying database
but you know this is left up to the sres
and if we can provide that as or as
sres our developers just are fine
they're going to be just fine
because they're going to want to use
something like node.js
and a rest api or graphql
and not think about oh do i need to
download a driver
um that's don't need to do that so
it really gives us the ability to
separate out
our traffic from our data traffic
from the actual database itself and they
can scale independently
um and then as new apis start popping up
we can add those and start building out
this whole infrastructure
the architecture right now for what
stargate does
is it has a the first layer is is
basically
just it accepts http calls
uh from a variety of places and then
negotiates with the underlying databases
right now it uses cassandra because that
was the first implementation
um there are other databases that are in
in
the pipeline as they say um there's
other open source
database projects that will that will
participate in stargate
and make those happen and that's the
point of this is making it just so that
we could have
a meeting place for databases to present
themselves as a data service and if you
think about it
in terms of like this is very modular
just like how kubernetes is very modular
we can build out all the different parts
and those parts
are how we deploy things into our
infrastructure
um just like if we build storage network
and storage network and compute
in kubernetes that's how we consume
things we can do the same things with
our data layer
the other project that i've been pretty
heavily involved with is a project
called kate sandra
and this is a little more into the
database side
for sure but what we're trying to do is
take cassandra and completely eliminate
it
as a an operations problem
and make it easier for people to deploy
it into kubernetes
but ultimately with the goal of making
it so that it's just a data layer for
kubernetes um you're not really thinking
about what the database is
um yeah i know the word kate sandra is a
little bit of a mashup and it's cute
but you should be able to deploy it and
have
the three things that i talked about you
should be able to have
an always-on uh elastic scaling
high-scaling data service without a lot
of work
um it's it should be an sre topic that's
pretty simple and your developers should
get what they need out of it
so the things that are built on
um we use an operator internally for
cassandra
um we prov we use stargate so it
implements stargate to provide a data
gateway
so when you deploy it it has um it has
all the services that you your
developers need
and then it uses uh it works with
traffic in this case but it works with
others as well for kubernetes ingress
and then it has operations tools that
run automatically in the background for
all the
operations tasks that normally you would
have to do manually
it does those automatically and
this is when we put all this together
with metrics and observability you get a
pretty usable package that
you deploy pretty easily you just deploy
it developers can use it any way they
need to you can deploy it anywhere
and this is where open source really
look at every one of these things is
open source so
if you wanted to point at amazon you
wanted to put it in google you wanted to
play it on your laptop
totally cool and it's portable
and it's you know we have in open source
there's freeze and freedom
and freezing beer this is freezing
freedom
you don't have to be tied up into a
certain wall garden
you can you can move it around however
you need to
and because these projects are all open
source you can
also do a lot of manipulation and
changes um so one of the things with
kate sander that's really exciting
is it's a lot less about code
contributions from the community and if
you look at the prs
it's a lot it's it's a lot less about
code and a whole lot more about
configuration
deploying like how you deploy things so
it's
it's turning into like a collection area
of sre knowledge
around deploying scale applications in
kubernetes
and then we use helm eventually for a
lot of this stuff to get deployed
um hell makes it easy it's right now
this
it's the the first class in the project
but
um we will i think we'll see soon it'll
be departing it'll split away from helm
so the the idea here is whenever you're
building applications
um and if you think about like all the
things that
interact with your data layer um it's
creating some abstractions inside
of kubernetes that allow for that to
happen so if your web and mobile apps
microservices etc
need a data service um this will provide
that in kubernetes
and it'll run on any infrastructure
because it's just running in kubernetes
um the keys are really just making sure
that you know you have
uh a stable or kubernetes cluster and
um some of the knowledge that we are
building now is around things like
making good storage choices how to work
with ingress that sort of thing
so back to my slide so
stargate is kind of the tip of the
iceberg in this case where it's just
like
here's the here's this little nice light
little piece of ice floating on the
water nothing to see here
all that messy detail is handled
automatically underneath through case
sandra
and this is an interesting this is
what's interesting about this is that
we're building up projects within
projects we're starting to wrap projects
and projects but
um kubernetes is the destination for
i think all of our application
infrastructure eventually at least in
the next 10 years and we're
really trying to make this a place where
everyone can gather
and bring knowledge and share and create
a community
around building data services and no
matter what underlying database you have
no matter what deployment infrastructure
you're using
so that is all i have